so without further ado please show some
love to Mike margulies and Michael
Pollan yeah thank you
Hey thank you okay if you haven't seen
the mushroom cure you're missing out yes
that's a wonderful show it's really
awesome and Adams
that you saw how awesome he is
definitely recommend it thank you all
for being here thank you everyone who's
tuning in live out of curiosity how many
of you have already read the book okay
potential converts tons of them yeah and
if you're watching live we have a
hashtag it's hash tag pollen live where
you can engage with this conversation
I'm really excited actually to be here
with you today and this book I think
does a really good job of taking us on
your own journey
it's got how to change your mind and I
think it's a statement of yourself and
how you changed your own mind because in
the beginning of the book you start off
actually pretty skeptical and very
material minded yeah and as you go
through it you sort of talk with the
researchers have your own first-hand
experiences and by the end of the book
you kind of close with a changed mind ya
know the the journey that this book
records is a very it's a public journey
in that it's a work of science
journalism and history but it's also a
personal journey I you know I began with
the typical journalistic curiosity and I
was interviewing people who were
participating in these trials at NYU and
at Johns Hopkins we met in Baltimore
when I was doing a recording yeah that's
when we first met and I was talking to
people many of whom who were
psychedelically naive who had had these
powerful
transformative experiences there were
people who are dying they were cancer
patients in some cases there were
smokers and they were so-called healthy
normals and all of them were not all of
them but about 80% of them and had this
very powerful experience that left them
changed and as I talked to them I became
intensely curious about how a molecule
could account for such a psychological
shift you know a complete change in
perspective and but over time I actually
grew to envy the people I was I was
interviewing and that they had had these
big spiritual epiphanies and I've never
had one I had never had one I was kind
of I always thought of myself as kind of
spiritually [ __ ] and and so I got I
got really jealous of them and and
that's when I decided that write about
this properly I would have to educate
myself and have a series of psychedelic
journeys and that those yeah they proved
to be transformative yeah and I actually
want to really zero in on that well you
said that the fact that you had your own
experiences I think is really increasing
for this process there's one thing to
the data is great but how how can we
talk about the psychedelic experience
about the psychedelic experience and the
fact that you've written a book that is
getting such publicity where you speak
very candidly I'm very vulnerable about
your own experiences that gives a lot of
space for other people to then come out
of the psychedelic closet and I think
and that and that is sort of that's been
one of the interesting phenomena I mean
there's the book and then there's the
reaction of the book which has actually
taught me and other people in the
community quite a bit about where the
culture is and it's been fascinating to
watch but the number of times I've sat
with a journalist doing the conventional
interview about your new book where
they've turned off the tape recorder and
said
can I tell you a story right right and
they have some really big experience
that they haven't talked to anybody
about in like 30 years and it was
something that actually still they're
still processing and my writing my is
someone who apparently has a reputation
as a affable same person that I was
writing about this gave them license to
talk about it and I've been through this
over and over and over again with
journalists and with people who come to
my events last night I was in Santa Cruz
and this woman came up to me with like
very large eyes and said I know exactly
what you meant I described this ego
dissolving experience I had had and she
said I melted into the creek alongside
Route 17 and these goats came up and
they were sipping me and and now ever
and this is 30 years ago but every time
I see a goat her ego dissolved so I
don't know what to do with this but let
me know yeah but but but I do think that
phenomenon of coming out of the closet
is really important and because that's
how you normalize things we've been
through that with you know gay rights
and and so many other things that the
willingness to have a matter-of-fact
discussion about something that is
considered stigmatized or taboo is how
you begin to remove that stigma and
taboo and so I've been kind of gratified
that to the extent that I've been
willing to speak in a matter-of-fact way
on national television or to any
audience about this and that people have
responded in kind makes me think that
there is a shift underway yeah yeah and
and I've really resonates with me
because this is the same reason I got
motivated
to join this community I don't even know
this but we entered the psychedelic
community at least publicly nearly an
identical time this dislike of that
psychedelic seminars was started
February 2015 which of course is the way
when I published my New Yorker piece
yeah yep that was the first piece of
content ever shared in this Facebook
page and and I came into this with a
very similar motivation as it was sort
of like I want to live in a world where
I had transformative experiences and I
want to not feel shame to speak openly
and honestly about my own experiences
and so you know you have to be the
change you want to see so I had to do
that and create that space for others
and lo and behold many organizations at
the same time actually very
synchronously other what other people
started similar psychedelic societies in
cities all around the world
yeah I've been amazed at the at the
there's this flowering or mushrooming be
more appropriate of psychedelic
societies what are there more than a
hundred now yeah there's something like
a hundred of them around the world and
you can get a psychedelic dot community
you can find them if you search on
organizations under psychedelic
societies it's it's really tremendous I
think there is a shift happening in part
because of the research that you
document in the book also in part
because of the book itself you've
obviously put a much more mainstream
lens on the psychedelic movement and so
one thing I'm really interested to talk
with you about here is with this
increased awareness of the potential for
psychedelics where can we go wrong with
this movement and I don't mean another
crackdown
I mean if being stay right on course
mmm-hmm what are the potential pitfalls
that we might encounter
well before we go there we should just I
think we should talk about what the
potential is because I don't know that
everybody in the audience realizes and
the center at the center of this book is
a story about a scientific Renaissance
and the fact is that much to my surprise
long before Timothy Leary came along in
the 60s which is with the 60s is kind of
branded psychedelics for most of the
culture and from there and perhaps many
people in the room but but long before
Timothy Leary had his first
transformative experience by a pool in
Cuernavaca on psilocybin in 1960 there
had been a
kid of really fertile research trying to
figure out what these amazing molecules
were and could do and then trying to
understand how they might be applied
therapeutically and so they went through
a whole you know set of changing
paradigms and they gradually kind of
coalesced around the idea that these
drugs could be very useful in treating
addiction there's a lot of work on
alcoholism in the 50s and in treating
depression and anxiety and and there was
you know I don't think people realize
but there were a thousand peer-reviewed
papers about LSD and psilocybin before
1965 and there was something like 40,000
research subjects six international
conferences on LSD
it was considered a psychiatric wonder
drug for for among many people in the
psychiatric establishment and this
research died F basically had faded out
after the counterculture embraced
psychedelics and there was a there was a
moral panic around them and lots of
horror stories many of which you know
we've all heard and and I believed
frankly most of them when I started this
work and then the research resumed and
this happens I mean I'm making it sound
way too simple it took a lot of work to
get it off the ground to get the FDA and
the DEA tour people here that were
involved and there are people in this
room who helped push it forward against
tremendous odds but beginning in the
late 90s you once again had this
resumption of serious and I'm talking
about rigorous controlled trials of
psilocybin especially because LSD was
still you know for two reasons LSD was
much more controversial much more likely
to run into a political buzzsaw and
psilocybin which most politicians have
never heard of and and also that frankly
LSD takes too long you know you'd have
to have pay overtime to all your
therapists if their guiding an LSD trip
whereas psilocybin kind of fits into the
workday pretty well
so so there have been a series of trials
and they've been very you know there's a
lot of really good data it's still
preliminary and there are many more
steps there's more phase two trials
there phase three trials that have to
happen before the FDA will approve it
but that's the path were on and and by
the way that path was marked by maps the
organization and Rick Doblin who made a
study of the who made a study he went to
Harvard to get a PhD in government or
administration so he on so he could
really understand what you had to do to
get a drug through the FDA and he
charted the path that both psilocybin
and MDMA haha we're getting psychedelic
here yeah
the best laugh of the night as the mics
so yeah I think you know Rick is a great
example actually of someone who being
back to individual can have really and
really pushing something forward also
Bob Jessie who's in the audience here
tonight and yeah Bob is Bob is less well
known than yes then maybe not anymore
yes Manor fewer interviews than Rick
spends much more time off the record
than Rick but he has been a key mover
and when the history is written in fact
history was written in my book he will
he is a very important player yes who's
never sought any recognition for his
work who has really helped drive forward
especially the work on psilocybin and
the work being done at at Johns Hopkins
in particular yeah and I'm actually very
glad that he is someone who's showcased
in Chapter one he I know Bob was
probably shy about it but I've told him
if there's anybody I'm happy that they
have a more of a platform now it's it's
Bob so I definitely have a lot of
respect for the work he's done and and
you kind of compared Bob and Rick it's
kind of like very different personality
types opposites yeah but both very
important in moving this forward and so
now we're on this path for FDA approval
so you wanted to know what could go
wrong yeah and and specifically I would
love for you to draw on your prior
experience writing about food yeah and
we have well we work that out that's why
I moved on yeah right we've worked that
out so you know in the as you've
documented in a lot of your prior work
there are a lot of issues in the food
industry and so if we think about the
prospect of mainstreaming psychedelics
and a psychedelic industry in Irving
merging for-profit psychedelic
businesses what are the potential
pitfalls and and I'd like to in
particular give some examples here so
we're in a path where psilocybin can be
FDA approved here's the asterisk it's
gonna be synthetic psilocybin not from a
mushroom it's got to be GMP grade it's
got to be given to you by a doctor it's
got to be given to you indoors in a
clinic
so we might have access to psychedelics
but you can't grow your own mushrooms
you can't forge your own mushrooms
people like Paul Corbett we ran an
article about him in symposia he was
arrested for picking wild mushrooms
that'll still happen
you won't be able to even trip outdoors
this to me is kind of like well you can
buy potatoes and eggs from Monsanto but
you can't own a chicken or a garden but
you can't people do own chickens and
they do own records and and you know
that so the monopoly is not a very
perfect monopoly and I don't think
personal and private use of mushrooms
will go away because there is
fda-approved use of it and I think it's
important to realize I mean so I'm not
as terrified of that scenario as you are
I think that I think it's really
important that you have the that medical
pass even if it is a pharmaceutical path
yes because that will make the let's and
and we're all this is all assuming that
the therapy proves out and phase through
trials and gets approved by the FDA so
we're kind of assuming that it's a big
assumption but that if it is approved in
a medical setting and doctors can
prescribe it
the upside is there'll be wide access
anybody with health insurance will be
able to be covered by it so it becomes a
little less elite and a little more
accessible and that's a real positive
what does the pharmaceutical industry do
with psilocybin I think it's a kind of a
reach for them you know the problems
with Merck or some big company getting
into psychedelics are many one is
where's your intellectual property I
mean these mushrooms grow anywhere and
the even the molecule well you can
patent biology now right well you can
but but not this molecule you can hat in
a delivery system a manufacturing method
but the fact is it's it's hard to get
your hands around and and have that kind
of control same with LSD that's off
patent also and so that may be one of
the reasons that big pharma doesn't so
far appear to have any interest here's
the other big problem psychedelic
therapy is a one time or a two time or
maybe a three time thing it's not a pill
you take every day and they're in the
business of selling pills people have to
take every day like SSRIs
antidepressants so how do you make money
if you're selling two or three pills to
somebody over the course of a lifetime
tell micro disss yeah well micro just
gave an idea to micros ting is probably
a better idea for the pharmaceutical
industry the problem with micro dosing
is no one has any idea if it's real or
not there's there's no science on
microdose it's there's science coming
now actually some is gonna be done
Beckley is proposed to do it i don't
know if that's going to get off the
ground but there's a couple other things
going on around the world but maybe in a
year or two we'll have you know one of
the reasons i didn't go into great
detail on micro dosing is that there's
no good science about it yet it could be
all placebo effect and there's nothing
wrong with that and I hope the research
doesn't louse up your placebo effect but
but yes there is a pill you take several
times a week you know you can sell that
and I can see it in little packs like
birth control pills you know with every
third you know there's there's a couple
sugar pills and then you get your micro
dose phone and but so will the
pharmaceutical industry jump in the
other problem with it is it's not really
simply a drug it's and we call it
psychedelic therapy but we really should
call it psychedelic assisted psycho that
sees about maps it's calling it yeah
they do although in some of the studies
it's interesting to watch how the
researchers play this when they're doing
the studies that go you know that are
part of the drug trials they try to they
try to play down the role of the
and frankly the role the psychedelic
guide is central I mean these drugs are
so powerfully affected by set and
setting that it is only in the company
of somebody you really trust who knows
the territory that someone can have the
you know surrender to the experience in
a way that it can make it productive
yeah and so so really it's a package
that's being tested and that's that's
weird for the the industry or even the
medical system you know normally we have
talked therapy over here and we have you
know a psychoactive drug therapy over
here but now we're gonna have to combine
them in this very novel package which is
exciting and you know we never should
have separated the mind in the brain
right I mean this brings them back
together but that too is like how do we
even the psychiatrist's work that out
you know you it's it's all day with two
therapists or at least two people in the
room so all that is gonna have to be
figured out and and I think these are
real challenges so you know before the
Mercs of the world of the Johnson &
Johnson's get involved I think there's
going to be probably much more activity
in the nonprofit sector yeah and so far
you know it's been nonprofit money that
has charitable contributions that has
funded most of the work it's amazing to
have a drug going through this process
without a big corporation behind it but
that's what we're seeing yeah and a lot
of contributions from people in this
city in particular I probably a lot map
stoners in this room as well
Maps donors and other people who are
supporting there's something called the
psychedelic science funding
collaborative which is a relatively new
organization that is collecting
donations and and has had great success
and enough money has been raised to
actually get through the whole drug
trial process that that's amazing yeah
but in but going back to your question
about about the problems ahead you have
to you know one of the questions that
bob jesse sensitized me to is what about
people who are not
Jahlil who stands adamant of well these
birds as he puts it this beautiful
phrase the betterment of well people how
can we serve those people what and is
does that argue for outright
legalization or decriminalization or or
what yeah and I think this kind of gets
back to maybe the core of what I was
getting you mentioned access and I guess
to clarify my earlier statements don't
get me wrong I support the FDA research
by all means I want to see those
fda-approved containers for medical
therapeutic use of psychedelics to exist
my concern is if they become the
exclusive containers you're a new priest
class that controls access to
psychedelics and as you know thinking
about access right our medical system as
it is is pretty broken and there isn't
equal access to medicine and the war on
drugs itself is a war on medicine in
many ways as we're seeing with how you
know the schedule one drugs arguably are
you know that have no medical use are
arguably the things with the most
medical use yeah at least potential for
abuse yeah and the least potential for
abuse this is the the big irony of our
situation and in many ways I mean it's
look at cannabis as an example I see a
lot of issues with cannabis in
particular with respect to questions
like access even in places where there's
legalization you know cuz you can go and
buy cannabis from the legalized
distributor but I can't even buy weed
for my neighbor I can't have there's no
farmers markets for weed and do we you
know is this the best model that we can
come up with and I guess I'm put it I
don't know the answer to this question
but I'm putting it out there like are
there better models and where we don't
where we create safe access to
containers to have an experience with it
with it is important to have an
experienced facilitator but can we do
that without criminalizing other methods
without putting people into prisons for
picking mushrooms yeah etc and I don't
know the answer to this yeah I don't
know yeah I mean I I do think that it
should be decriminalized I don't I don't
think that that's a I think picking your
own mushrooms but I also think that the
cannabis model which is kind of like you
know that we see in California might not
be right here
just because I I mean my own experience
and interviewing dozens of people who
had been through psychedelic therapy is
that these drugs are uniquely powerful
and that the role of the guide is very
important to a to a successful
experience it's not to say people
haven't had terrific experiences you
know taking mushrooms or LSD and you
know going to I just talked to someone
who went to a festival last weekend and
had a fantastic experience you know
that's all true but there is another
kind of experience people have to and
you know given a poor set and setting
and said as you're in you know your
internal environment and your external
environment setting people have you know
experiences that really rock them
psychologically and and leave people in
a really bad place and so how do you
mitigate that risk and I do think that
the the idea of a guide a train guide is
a very important way you know the the
big lesson part of the issue with
psychedelics in our society is they kind
of burst upon our culture in the 50s and
60s without any preparation suddenly
these incredibly powerful interesting
molecules show up psilocybin is
discovered in Mexico by the first
Westerner Gordon Wasson in 1955 he
writes a big article in Life magazine
and suddenly people want it and descend
on this town in Mexico and then LSD is
invent is discovered or really tried out
in the 40s and and becomes this drug of
research and but we got the molecule
without the package we got the molecule
without the traditions the rituals the
ceremonial rites of passage the right
yeah the rites of passage so if you look
back the history of psychedelics which
is so much older than the 50s and 60s in
America in Europe you see that that many
cultures use these drugs these medicines
in a very carefully designed context you
never see people using them alone and
this
whether we're talking about ancient
Greece Siberia
you know the Amazon Central America they
never used the drugs alone it was always
with elders or shamans or curanderos
presiding and there was always ceremony
in ritual and there's a reason for that
yeah it's not just superstition it's the
fact that there was enormous respect for
the power of these these medicines and
that they shouldn't be used carelessly
and you know it was a capital crime in
Greece the Greeks had us what we think
is a psychedelic ceremony once a year
the Elysium mysteries and there was a
potion they took that appears to have
been a psychedelic it allowed people to
travel to the underworld and meet the
dead and and enter other realms you
could only use this medicine in that
ceremony and it was it was a capital
crime you could be you could be executed
for using it recreationally and and I
used that word advisedly but so there
was a reason for all that and and the
kind of individualistic use that you
know we've pioneered in the West you
know may not be the best yeah so I think
we have to be open to that and and be
willing to learn from history absolutely
and I've been that guy who took
psychedelics in the wrong context I was
the guy paranoid at Burning Man you know
too paranoid to even go to the zendo
project so and then whereas when I did
psychedelics I actually was a
participant at Johns Hopkins and in that
setting with meri kasam ah no who's
probably experienced it
there's also had more more more trips
than anybody and at least above the
modern above-ground in the modern period
of research yeah and it's really my
figure yes and which reflects what you
were getting at before the importance of
the facilitator in that and it's the
importance of a facilitator who can take
on a passive role but it's act
it's almost active passive
you know someone who is not guiding your
experience but they are able to but they
there is a really active holding of
space there yes
and that jargon you know is I mean it's
actually pretty accurate I mean it's
it's to my ear it sounds a holding space
but but there but I came to appreciate
it because what's happening in these
experiences is a when it's a high dose
therapeutic experience you you are your
ego may well be dissolving and with it
your defenses right we have these
defenses that are serve us they get in
our way too but they serve us and to
feel comfortable putting down all your
defenses you have to feel really safe
and if you do that in the wrong setting
and you fight to hold on to your sense
of self and your defense this is when
you get paranoid and have a really awful
experience so it takes a certain skill
it takes a certain compassion and meri
kasam oh no hasn't more than probably
anybody to to create that space where
you you feel comfortable enough to put
down every defense you have built up
over the course of your life it's a huge
gesture of trust and great things can
come from it
but it will only come in the right
setting yeah and I think you know and to
get back to the question of yeah the
importance of the guides and how do we
how do we reconcile this right with say
decriminalization and I like I may be
borrowing this idea from somebody but I
think about scuba diving I scuba dive
right and so always have a buddy right
you always have a buddy right but it's
let's say hypothetically I was gonna
strap on a scuba tank jump in the water
without a license right very dangerous
thing to do right but there wouldn't be
like you wouldn't need police to come
and arrest me right for doing that right
it's just known in the culture that
scuba diving is dangerous scuba diving
is dangerous so if you're gonna go scuba
diving you should get a training you
should get a certification yeah and that
people won't take you and dive if you
haven't got in the safety training you
don't need to enforce that with prisons
but you enforce it with education and
enforce it but you just use education
and I think there's a
and so that which gets me to with
psychedelics what's the best way that we
can create an alternative model well
let's talk about the risks of
psychedelics let's make it more
culturally known like there is obviously
tremendous positive potential which is
not to be downplayed whatsoever in all
these studies but I think if we have a
respect and an awareness for the risks
of psychedelics and what can go wrong
that's where we just culturally create
it's like anyone who's thinking about
doing it yeah of course you should go
see someone who's trained to do this
thing yeah and embed that in the culture
that the importance of that facilitator
yeah I think so and also there are lots
of people who don't want to be
underground with their with whatever
they do and would feel so much more
comfortable if there were such a thing
as a licensed psychedelic guide who
could prescribe or perhaps worked in an
institution that had an MD involved who
could do the prescription and that
opened I mean talk about access that
opens it up to lots of people who aren't
comfortable buying drugs underground and
and not being sure that of the strength
of what they're getting so I I can
definitely see a situation where we have
such people and in fact ci is in this
yes the Californians to for integral
studies it has a training program now to
Train psychedelic guides most of whom
will work in these trials these drug
trials that are going to be happening
but it you know it's I attended this one
of the several of their sessions and
there are people who see this as a
profession that they want to they want
to enter how amazing I mean five years
ago you can't imagine something like
this yeah and no shortage of need here
no I think there's going to be an
explosion of demand and I think it's I
mean if you talk about things that can
go wrong my worry is that some as people
learn more about the science and as more
science is done the demand for a
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy will
be so great that it will overwhelm the
number of guides we have with the result
that you'll have lots of charlatans
appearing right hanging out shingles
I'm a psychedelic guide right and you
know bad things can happen you know I
mean you were I mean I talked about how
vulnerable you are imagine the
opportunities for you know sexual abuse
and this is actually happening today
people go to Peru for ayahuasca and the
bad things happen yes yes this is a
major issue in the community right now
actually yeah yeah so there it's it's
not going to be simple you know this is
but this is cultural innovation I mean
this is you know we'll learn in the same
way those those traditional cultures
gradually learn to create the proper
container for the psychedelic experience
our culture needs to do that work too
and it may not be simply the medical
container right you know the white what
I call white coat shamanism and we have
our own shamans they're called doctors
and and that makes some people very
comfortable but that it seems to me
would be a little too limited yeah I
agree
can I ask you some tough questions yeah
sure
all right these have been so easy I want
to address because a lot of people in
audience today are actually from the
psychedelic community and so and people
have been working in this community for
some time and so there's been criticisms
come they have come back towards you and
I'd like to just give you the
opportunity to address directly right so
the first which being like okay so why
are we why do we care about what Michael
Pollan has to say about this is outsider
let so to speak from this from this
psychedelic space there's the things in
the book have been talked about before
why is everyone so excited now and and
why should we listen to your angle on
this whole thing well nobody has to know
it was anyone coerced by my book you
know I am an outsider this book is
written from the perspective of someone
who was fairly psychedelically naive who
got interested and entered this
community there is a perspective though
that the newcomer has that no one else
ever has again I mean I learned this a
long time ago as a writer one of the
most influential books I read
when I was 13 was a book called paper
lion by George Plimpton anybody know who
that is
yeah okay so he was a he was also the
editor of The Paris Review and he
reinvented sports writing by instead of
just being on the sidelines chomping on
a cigar he decided he was going to train
with the Detroit Lions and he persuaded
them to do it and actually play
quarterback in a scrimmage game in
during spring training summer training
and that gave him a perspective that not
only the sideline sports writers had
never had but the players had never had
because they took it for granted they've
been playing football their whole life
they were used to getting their heads
bashed in you knows that was normal I
don't mean to liken any of you two to
you know football players getting their
heads bashed in but but the fact is
there's something about first sight
first experience that opens up something
that you never recapture again so I
think that my my newness to the
experience contribute something and and
it certainly allowed me to write about
it yes in a way that is hard to do if
you have a lot of experience and then
there is the fact that I come you know
that most books about psychedelics and I
don't say this to criticize them have
been written from within the community
and I have to tell you the people
outside the community those books like
might be written in another language yes
they're like they're Greek to a lot of
people and that so my my reluctance the
fact that I had so many so much
resistance I had to overcome I mean fear
of the drugs distaste for the music
reluctance about the New Age lingo I
mean there were so many things I had to
get over that I think that creates a
perspective that that or becomes a door
for people in the mainstream to take a
look at this world so to me I think
that's the value added of having
you know someone is not an expert yeah
and also as a writer I don't like
writing as an expert one of the reasons
I left food is I'd become an expert and
it's much less it's much more fun to
write at the beginning of the learning
curve and let your readers learn with
you yes and bring them on the journey
instead of completing the journey and
then standing up and lecturing them and
that's all that's a whole other way to
write and it's not what I do I totally
agree with that and I want to add to
that as well you spent what four years
researching this book you know talking
to researchers around the world taking
psych adults yourself
that's nothing to you know scoff at here
you spent four years researching them
you know it's it's true yeah and I still
don't think I'm an expert I mean I still
have a lot to learn but also you know
even those people in the communities
some of them some of them know about the
history some of them don't some of them
know about the neuroscience some of them
don't
so I think that even for people in the
community there's material that may be
unfamiliar yeah well you don't have the
depth of these experts but a breadth of
knowledge yeah I think there's value in
that generalist yeah I also bring the
perspective of someone who's worked on
plants for a very long time and has been
interested in nature and I put this in
the context I mean if people people who
wonder how I got from food to
psychedelics well they're both about
nature they're things we take into our
body that change us we change them and
in the process and it's part of our
engagement with the natural world which
is fundamentally my topic as a writer
food is one branch on that tree
psychedelics and and psychoactive drugs
in particular or not yeah and another
thing I had a character they were crazed
in your book is Huxley yeah and he was
called on he's a writer he was called on
like put language to things right and I
think in many ways you're operating as
our kind of modern Huxley here yeah
getting language to things like from
particular one piece of language I
really appreciated was he talked about
the need for additional first-person
pronouns yeah what there is a strange
thing that happens to your first-person
pronoun and you realize the limitations
of our language when you know I say at
some point and I
I'd be held my my ego turning into a
sheaf of little post-its and like wait
who beheld that
how can you behold yourself and there is
the separation of of your yourself into
these parts that can happen that really
strains our language because our
language was not written to describe
psychedelic experience right and yeah so
that's the other you know that's the
toolkit I bring I'm a writer and when
you tell me something is ineffable
that's when I want to F it and so so and
you know look writing about trips is
really difficult just go on era with and
you'll see how difficult it is and so
you know if I having been a writer for
you know 35 years it was really an
interesting challenge and I love that
challenge and and I had more fun writing
those passages in this book than I've
ever had writing I mean you can judge
whether they succeed but it was an
interesting literary challenge and so
anyway yeah so my second tough question
yeah one of the main criticisms coming
from the psychedelic community as people
though that says I have observed that
many of the characters in the book are
people that look like me and you white
man are dominating the narrative so
there's questions around voices of women
and indigenous perspectives can you
speak to these critics yeah I mean ii
Delic world is very white and male in
America yes and I've noticed that from
the beginning most of the you know
people you most of the researchers are
white male most of the scientist which
was my focus and you look at the history
and most of the big characters in the
history have been white men do I
perpetuate that by writing about them I
guess I do there are some really
important female characters in this book
though
and some of them people of color maria
sabina for example the woman who turned
on gordon Wasson and really led to
brought psilocybin to the west
inadvertently and that was you know
that's not a happy story for her in the
end that that you know led to the
essentially the destruction of her
little village in oaxaca as celebrities
descended and her house was burned down
by her by people in the village they
were so mad at her she regretted having
done it but anyway there's a there's a
very important woman of color in this
narrative of the guides i work with i
work with three guides two of them were
women marry one of them is really kind
of the hero of the book in many ways are
there women that I overlooked I'm sure
there are and you know some of that is
no doubt a result of my perspective but
a lot of as a result of the history that
I was writing about you could write an
alternative history of psychedelics and
you could talk all about Albert
Hoffman's assistant and Gordon Watson's
wife and you know so there's is there a
feminist history of psychedelics to be
written I hope so and I hope somebody
writes it you know this is not the last
book on psychedelics I I think these
other perspectives need to be told I'm
not the best person to tell them perhaps
but but I hope there are many more books
to be written from a variety of
perspectives in terms of indigenous
peoples you know it's funny someone
stood up in Cambridge and and and said
something that I found really upsetting
she this was the the second day of my
book tour this woman stands up from the
Boston Anthea Jin Network maybe she's
watching and she says as the de facto
leader of the psychedelic community it
was a psychedelic movement I was like
really and you know and Rick Doblin was
in the room the real
and I turned him and I made him stand up
and absorb all this fear juju and and
then she went on to say you know how do
you answer the criticism that there
aren't more african-americans in the
psychedelic community actually she said
more people of color and there actually
are quite a few people of color if you
if you're willing to go beyond the
borders of America and look at people in
South America and Central America and
you know the shamanic tradition there
are tons of people of color involved in
ayahuasca for example but she I think
she was thinking about African Americans
in it that's a really interesting
question I would get the same question
about food you know why aren't why don't
we have more people of color involved in
the food movement and there are
legitimate questions and and but first
you know I'm not a leader I mean you
just made the point I'm a newcomer how
can I be a leader I don't know enough to
advocate I'm still learning but people
are hungry for leadership definitely so
anyway there are you know my focus
though I think I wasn't trying to write
the comprehensive history of
psychedelics in the world
I was really writing at the center of
this book is a renaissance of scientific
research Western scientific research I'm
interested in the shamanic tradition
insofar as it influences that and and so
I go off from that spine but that's fine
is science and that science is is you
know is it's pretty white and pretty
male hmm so let's actually talk about
the science here and as specifically as
it relates to some of your prior work in
food right and you talked about things
like nutritionism right and we got into
this weird point with food where you
know we've invented white bread yeah
where we took things out and then we
really took out the healthy things and
then we had nutrient-enriched white
bread and so as you put it you you put
the the problem on the solution in the
same packet maybe packaging and so the
point being that we had was clever
science but maybe at all along nature
was had it right to begin with so let's
make an analogy here to mushrooms
we're doing all this research on
psilocybin is it possible that if we
focus
this one nutrient yeah the psilocybin
are we missing something important in
the whole it's completely possible I
don't know the answer for sure I mean
there are actually two chemicals in
psilocybin there's solo sentence ivan
but there may be other compounds too and
they may be relevant and they and also
there may be different compounds that
you know philosophy cubensis which is
the main mushroom most people use is
only one of a hundred and fifty
different psilocybin species does as
arrestins have other stuff in it it
seems to have some slightly different
effects so and we know this in cannabis
right you know we know there are two
famous cannabinoids THC and CBD but
there are many many more when people
started fooling around with
beta-carotene or you know these they
thought that you know the key to the
carrot is this this antioxidant called
beta carotene and they then they turned
it into a pill and they gave it to
people thinking it would help them and
in fact it hurt them the death rate from
cancer went up in people who were eating
the supposedly good nutrient well it
turns out that they're you know 49 other
carotenes in a carrot and and we haven't
studied most of them so we should be
very respectful of the of the mushroom
as nature gives it to us and at least
explore the possibility that there are
other things going on that are valuable
it's you know there are cases when you
know we synthesize things successfully
and effectively but our tendency is is
to is reductive and you know for science
you need to be reductive right you need
to isolate that chemical to perform a
drug trial but I think we should be
aware that there may be you know same
the difference between peyote and
mescaline I mean you know has anyone
really explored that I don't know the
answer but the other parallel from food
that I think is really relevant and I'm
glad you brought this up is eating alone
mmm you know we one of the one of the me
trends in western food is the move from
eating as a communal act to eating as
something you do in the car
you know 46% of meals are eaten alone
now 20% are in the car and this kind of
atomized individualistic eating turns
out not to be very good for your health
because people eat too much from they
eat alone whereas when you eat at a
table with other people other things are
going on you're talking you're
conversing and and you eat in a more
moderate way and so there's something
about socializing an experience that can
make it healthier and that may be true
with psychedelics - yeah I'm glad you're
bringing this up actually and we look in
the traditions a lot of the time
psychedelics are taken in groups
ayahuasca circles yes communal or in the
case of if we go to Gabon and we talk
about it boga it's actually the communal
aspect of that is almost reversed
there's one person in the getting
initiated and this may not be true in
all boutique traditions it's very
diverse in itself but there's initiate
and then the entire community is around
you supporting you and so the community
aspect not to mention integration and
all this other aspect and and right now
with the FDA approval process what we're
going toward is a single person with two
guys which seems it's a single person
but not alone not alone right like
eating with the chaperone at McDonald's
but we don't right you know it's not
really but but we really don't have a
necessarily right now a lot of sites a
group psychedelic work which i think
well i but i i think that's coming i
think one of the ways you'll deal with
the inefficiencies of two therapists and
one person and i think there's some
proposals of foot in at least I know in
Europe Bob Jesse you'll send me a memo
about this later if I'm wrong that of
looking at the possibility of doing
group psilocybin as a way to make you
know that two therapists could actually
work on six people at once yeah or eight
people and I think that's worth
exploring I mean certainly that's the
ayahuasca model you're right and I know
it Maps has a study for couples therapy
actually yeah where one person in the
couple has PTSD
and so and they're actually treating the
couple collectively because they're both
affected by the PTSD and this gets into
the broader dynamics of socially you
know we're not just isolated individuals
yeah that that's true of the cancer
studies too they're people like
Katherine MacLean who makes the argument
and it's a very good argument that the
caregivers can benefit just as much from
psilocybin therapy as the person who's
dying and that it's a whole
constellation that's affected by that by
that event and the grief and there's
actually a study of AIDS survivors with
psilocybin that's about to start at San
Francisco and that is treating the
survivor not the not the patient so I
think there's you know there's so much
more to be learned and there's so many
exciting experiments to do and what's
what's really wonderful is that this
space has been created by these pioneers
in the end the you know the willingness
of the FDA to go along with this because
they have been basically encouraging of
the research in recent years that we're
gonna learn a lot we're gonna learn a
lot about the mind and about you know
the way it works and the way it
sometimes fails to work in the next few
years and that psychedelics in addition
to being interesting of themselves are
gonna prove to be a very powerful tool
for understanding addiction and dying
and depression and anxiety and the mind
and consciousness and that's to me is
really exciting you know Stan Grof had
that the the legendary psychedelic
psychiatrist who's still with us he said
once and I remember reading this early
in my research and thinking that is
ridiculous
he said that psychedelics or LSD would
be for the study of the mind what the
telescope was for astronomy and what the
microscope was for biology
it was really an audacious thing to say
especially then but actually I no longer
think that's crazy at all I mean I think
that psychedelics do have very important
things to do
yeah so I think we're about time for
questions the audience here so I hand
going up there and very going on there
so gonna be a microphone right here yeah
that's yeah there we go we are live all
right so we will gladly take questions
starting right here and then we're
actually gonna form a line over there
behind so the second person in line go
ahead over there that's not a shy group
so yeah so go ahead you can be second
but just go over there so that's where
the line will be yeah you're good you
were first yeah you're first you're good
all right perfect
thank you all right wonderful
so on behalf of all of us here like huge
thank you for doing what you've done
both of you for hosting an event as well
as for taking this big step in getting
rid of some of the taboo around
psychedelics thank you yeah and I yeah
thank you
I want to actually yeah you wanna yeah
why not a disclaimer here we are
live-streaming so just bear in mind if
you do come ask a question you will be
on the Internet it's true displeasure
that's true full disclosure hahaha
all right cool I have a quick question
to launch it off so as much as the
beauty of being able to quell the ego
it's so important for civilization where
does that come into play for children
how do we know how do we know at what
age and like is it appropriate it's and
it's not appropriate for everyone so
what do you what are your thoughts about
that
yeah I don't know when when it's
advisable for people to start using
psychedelics and I haven't really
explored that but it's important to
understand that the structures that
psychedelics melt are formed you know a
little later in life young children I
talk about young children in the book
and in fact there's a whole passage
about this brilliant child psychologist
at Berkeley who really believes that the
consciousness of children under five or
so is very similar to the psychedelic
consciousness and she basically thinks
little kids are tripping all the time
and they if you've had one you know that
they do and but they don't have a
default mode network we haven't talked
about that but that's the network in the
brain that appears to go quiet or be
quieted during the psychedelic
experience and that doesn't develop till
they go to school and begin to develop a
sense of themselves as consistent beings
over time that you know you're not born
feeling that way and you know
personality doesn't really kind of gel
until your early 20s
so it's a curious time to to dissolve
your personality before that
and you know for some people it's fine
and for other people that's I think very
challenging and one quick follow-up to
that and it's something that I think
many people are curious about where do
we strike a balance between nationalism
and globalism seems to be one of the
most pressing things that's going on in
the world is how do we beat foster a
collective consciousness across the
globe but also how do we ensure that we
can thrive as the United States at the
same time where do you how do you strike
a balance with that as well well you
know I think one of the interesting
things about psychedelics is that they
potentially address two of the biggest
challenges we face as a civilization one
is the environmental crisis our
disconnection from nature and the other
is tribalism our disconnection from
people who are unlike us one of the
amazing things that happens on a
successful psychedelic experience is a
reconnection with nature you you no
longer objectify the other one of the
things the ego does is patrol these
borders between self and other self and
nature and self and subconscious and
when you put those down when you quiet
those voices is when you can connect to
the other in a very profound way and and
I described experiences I had with
nature where I saw nature in a
completely different way I was a part of
it part and parcel of it not an observer
not a spectator and did it with other
people I mean the most common you know
experience people report is this feeling
of this flood of love for other people
whether in their lives or people very
unlike them and you know is there
anything we need more right now the
challenge is though how do you go from
creating those experiences in
individuals to creating it across the
society and we there is no model for
administering a drug to an entire
society Mike microdose the whole foods
buffet well or I mean we do have we do
have fluoride but I think psychedelics
are very different than fluoride so I
can potentially give you an opportunity
to talk a little bit about the default
mode Network can you talk some about
that and
and just you know the potential value
and dissolving the ego yeah thanks for
bringing that up the neuroscience that I
learned about was to me intellectually
the most exciting part of doing this
book and and and that really is where
we're learning what we're learning about
consciousness in the mind so when when
neuroscientists first began imaging the
brains of people on psilocybin or LSD
they would actually like inject someone
with the medicine and slide them into
that fMRI tube and if you've ever been
in an fMRI and you've ever tripped
imagine combining those two things these
volunteers you know yeah deserve a hand
that's going to be in this study that is
serious volunteer duty what they
expected to see though was and this work
was first done in Imperial College
London by a brilliant neuroscientist
named Robin Carhartt Harris who I
profiled another white now I'm sorry to
report but there it is and and so they
expected to see lots of activity on the
fMRI and you know consistent with the
fireworks that people report but what
they saw instead was a reduction in
activity in this one particular network
that happens to be very important to our
sense of self and that is the default
mode Network and this is a set of
structures in the midline of the brain
that connects structures that are within
the cortex the evolutionarily most
recent part of the brain that has our
executive function and higher-order
functions with deeper older structures
involved with memory and emotion and
it's a hub in the brain lots of signals
passed through it it's like a Grand
Central Station or something and then
it's also a regulator as Robin calls it
it's the conductor of the neural
symphony it's and and so what does it do
well it's involved in self-reflection as
far as we know and self-criticism and
room and
it's where your mind goes when it's
wandering or worrying it's involved in
time travel the ability to think about
the future or the past which is very
important to a sense of identity without
a sense of time you don't have a sense
of identity
it's involved in a theory of mind which
is the ability to imagine mental states
and other people which is critical to
moral reasoning and ethical reasoning
and it's involved in something called
the experiential self this is kind of
where we generate the stories that
connect what happens to us at any given
time to this the story of who we are
so how interesting that when this
network goes quiet or appears to on an
fMRI that's when people report an
experience of complete ego dissolution
what good is that well the researchers
you know are still speculating about it
they do think that ego dissolution which
some refer to as the mystical experience
I actually think they're pretty much the
same thing one is a spiritual vocabulary
one is a psychodynamic vocabulary but
similar things happen when you lose a
sense of ego you you merged with other
things because the balls come down and
that permits a reconnection with other
people with nature with your past self
and that when our defenses are down we
can break out of the stories in which we
trap ourselves you know those really
destructive stories we tell about
ourselves and and depress people in
particular and addicts in particular the
story that says you can't get through
the day without a drink the story that
says that you you're unworthy of love we
get stuck in these loops of rumination
and recrimination and the psychedelic
experience of ego dissolution gives you
a new perspective it's temporary but you
see that wow you don't have to think
that way and those stories they're
they're broken they're there their power
over you is broken even if just for some
a period of time but having had a taste
of that other form of consciousness
where you're not the victim
of your loops of destructive thought can
be liberating so that's that's a that's
a theoretical hypothesis of how it works
but it's a compelling one yeah and I
think it's really interesting this idea
of decentralizing the brain and it's
very timely considering this theme a lot
people here probably from the blockchain
world you know this theme of
decentralization and so in many ways
psychedelics are like the you know these
centralizing the brains they might have
blockchains or decentralized and that
since they're anti hierarchical the
experience and and actually those of you
have the book in your lap look at page
318 sorry not everybody has it but go
outside and look at page 318 later and
there's a map of the brain on a placebo
and and on psilocybin and there and so
there's a perimeter in this map and
every circle represents a different
brain network that the brain is
organized in these networks one deals
with you know local motion one deals
with the visual cortex and there are a
few big highways in the first
illustration and when the default mode
network goes down all these new
connections form that have never existed
before the brain is temporarily rewire
and suddenly you have this explosion of
new pathways and we don't know what's
happening on those pathways they could
explain synesthesia right the phenomenon
of tasting a color that maybe the cross
wiring of two two brain networks or the
new insights or metaphors that people
report those may be a new way to connect
dots that's the exciting work is to
figure out what's going on in that new
map and what kind of thinking happens
but the fact is the brain is being wired
in a new way temporarily and that
temporary rewiring can have lasting
effects so you've been talking about the
reduction of stigma around speaking
openly about psychedelics you made a
parallel to courageous people who came
out during the gay rights move it and
their role in reducing stigma there
another parallel
observe is the importance of personal
experience amongst lawmakers in the gay
rights movement for example a lot of
traditionally conservative lawmakers
would have a courageous family member
who would come out as gay and they would
be conservative on all social issues
except for gay rights yeah because they
had that personal experience and my
question is is there a way for us to
push for sensible drug policy by finding
ways for getting people in government
lawmakers to have those personal
experiences that will open up their mind
about psychedelics short of dosing the
u.s. congressional cafeteria well maybe
we should start at the top yeah so we're
back to putting in the water supply I
don't know why you guys keep coming
around to that I just don't think that
that's ethical yeah but thank you for
the thought yeah I mean I and I guess I
want to add a friend Demetria giannis
has a really good thought bubble around
this I don't know that giving everyone
psychedelics is necessarily the answer
we have seen tremendous uh-huh promise
of course no it's not yeah it's I would
say it's definitely not the right answer
you know as Dmitri says of your
associate path and you do psychedelics
they'll make you a better sociopath yeah
so you know food for thought yeah no I
agree it's not automatically sweetness
in light there is the example of Charles
Manson right and you know the fact is
these drugs are incredibly suggestible
and you know we were told that the CIA
experiments in mind-control were
failures by the CIA you know so you can
you know could be could LSD be used to
brainwash someone it's not out of the
question you know I don't think we
should just assume that the that there's
an inherent tendency in the direction of
peace and love yeah these drugs because
there may not be you know as as we said
earlier set and setting or everything
and so imagine a
set in a bad setting yeah they're tools
like right a knife is a tool that's
going to use like cook a meal or to kill
somebody exactly yeah and so we have to
think about these tools pass to any tool
really and that's that's I think the
thing I'm most interested in having
these conversations about is not to get
around saying oh how great psychedelics
are but let's talk about the tremendous
potential they have but let's also be
realistic about the real risks that are
there and the way forward in my opinion
is not parade around saying it's either
either the extremes or he went in the
drug war Oh drugs are bad don't do drugs
they're terrible or the opposite extreme
oh yeah everyone take acid that'll save
the world but come on let's be balanced
and let's discuss honestly the benefits
and the risks yeah no I think so and
each drug on its own terms too because
they all get lumped together and it's a
very irrational if you look at the
scheduling of drugs that we have under
the Controlled Substances Act
it doesn't accord with anyone's very lot
of reality I would say even the
definition of a Schedule one substance
is pretty absurd it's that these have no
accepted medical use yeah and every
single thing on that list pretty much
bar none I'd say has a medical use
talking about psychedelics of course
talking about medical marijuana even
heroin if you go to the UK it's given in
hospitals you can look this up
everything on that list has a medical
use but anyway yes ok have you
encountered any sort of experiences
where psychedelics have been used to
address like short-term memory loss or
mental acuity that that's being degraded
over time and if the short answer to
that is no my backup question is can
could you talk a little bit about maybe
revisiting this space after having an
ego death that went bad or or maybe Mike
even your paranoia at Burning Man and
what the process is like for for
rejoining this this community thank you
the process for reintegrating after a
like a bad trip exactly or even just
thinking about this space and and and
views after the experience that you've
had yeah there's been some speculation
about neurogenesis on psychedelics but
you know from some of the researchers
and and some are interested in studying
whether there might be some value
in treating Alzheimer's or preventing
Alzheimer's but it hasn't gotten very
far yet it's it's it's kind of a
hypothesis there is a neuroplasticity
that seems to happen there's some some
mild evidence for that but bad trips why
don't you take that one yeah thank you
the honest answer is I'm still
recovering it I was hit very deeply and
ways that still affects me to this day
and it's a journey and I'm just trying
to find the lessons trying to figure out
what I can learn from the experience the
biggest gift I've gotten from that
experience is to be able to talk
honestly about having a bad trip so as I
do think it's important that we have
these discussions to thank you and you
know the the construct of the bad trip
is you know not used by the therapist
yeah they tend to they and the guides
they talk about a challenge interval
experience because if you have a bad
trip so called in the presence of a good
guide or a therapist it can be
incredibly productive because the
material that comes up is is good stuff
to work on right stuff you need to work
on probably and so they they you know
very often bad trips in the long-term
become very positive things
yes and actually it's a good opportunity
to talk about I alluded to earlier the
Zenda project and if you're not familiar
with Zenda project subsidiary of maps
and they go to Burning Man and other
festivals and provide psychedelic harm
reduction services for people who are
having these difficult experiences and
as you mentioned like the principle of
it is this they four principles one is
you're sitting and not guiding we talked
about before yeah very much like with
the therapy that you create a safe space
that you're talking someone through the
experience versus talking them down so
you don't want in someone's tripping and
you're sitting with them you don't want
to say oh but it's cool you're the
festival everything's all right you
don't want to minimize what they're
experiencing but you want to go right
through it
and ideally you can use this opportunity
and if you do it right a difficult
experience is not necessarily a bad one
and it can be an opportunity for
tremendous transformation yeah and there
are yeah well let's leave it there
because there's a lot of questions thank
you
that actually kind of goes into what I
was gonna ask about is if you want to
help people in a way where you want to
be able to guide them better through
those types of experiences how do you
recommend we begin our journey and
becoming a psychedelic guide of sorts or
maybe even actually becoming a
psychedelic guide well you know you
apprentice I mean there's two routes I
mean one is the above-ground route and
you go to the you know California
Institute for integral studies has a
guide training program that is an not
most I mean it's mostly non-resident
thing and you meet for seven weekends
and do an internship and you get your
certificate and you need some sort of
license you need as that's right and and
then the other way is there are you know
there are underground guides who train
who have you know apprenticeships and
that's the other way I've met people
who've gone through that so there are
there are a couple ways to do it we
can't tell you how to find them thanks
for being here today
so I actually haven't had a chance to
read your book yet but I was wondering
if you had any knowledge regarding the
study of ketamine and ketamine I've used
to study or to help heal depression I
actually was not aware of this until a
couple days ago I have a friend of mine
who works at John Hopkins and she was
telling me about this use for depression
so I was wondering if you could speak to
that science a little bit and what's
being done in that area thank you
sure so ketamine is not exactly a
psychedelic it's actually an anaesthetic
and it's a and it has been used in
anesthesia for a long time and it's
actually a relatively safe anesthetic it
has less impact on the cardiovascular
system doesn't depress it as much as
other some other anesthetics do it was
discovered that at lower doses than
one that knocks you out you have an
experience that some people describe as
a psychedelic experience and a kind of a
separation of self and that that has is
being used to treat depression the drug
is approved as an anesthetic and that
means that doctors can prescribe it
off-label for other things legally and
that's happening there are legal
ketamine clinics in this city and and
around the country and there's a lot of
excitement in the psychiatric community
about it I don't I didn't write about it
at great length I really did I don't
write about MDMA that much either I
really I limited myself to the to the
you know so-called classic psychedelics
in this book because they share a
history and they share a neuroscience
and there was a kind of logic to it and
I didn't want to you know it's already
400 pages so but ketamine is very
interesting and it appears that it
doesn't last that the the treatment
needs to be administered again I don't
know how often there's there's a very
good article by a very fine journalist
named Moises Velasquez Manoff that's in
the current or the last issue of Wired
so if you want to learn more about
ketamine that's a good place to start
there's also ketamine Conference coming
to the day I believe in news right yeah
so I don't know the details of it but if
you google the ketamine conference in
November like I think you'll find it how
are you just like to you know a lot of
LSD in the 60s and it was a whole trip I
wanted to know the difference when
you're taking it in therapy can you
explain a little bit about what's the
difference about taking it you know a
trip at home and and going to therapy
like for the PTSD yeah that's it that's
a great question so the big difference
is that you are that you're having more
of an internal trip so in all these
trials and this is also common
underground gods you were I shade which
to many people who have lots of
experience tripping outdoors concert
seems like a really weird idea and
you're indoors and you're lying down and
you're listening to music on headphones
we usually headphones not always
headphones and both the music is meant
to block out the rest of the environment
but it also has a positive function and
the eyeshades to our to limit
distraction and they basically encourage
you to go inside so you you have a very
different to the extent that there's no
there's a kind of interest psychic movie
that unrolls you know unfurls during the
psychedelic trip that's very much
created by your external environment if
you're walking around and you don't have
and your and your eyes are open but when
your eyes closed you just go somewhere
else and your imagination takes over and
you you are more likely to say visit
your cancer if you're a cancer patient
or have you know deal with repressed
memories things will come up so it's a
Morse you know internalized experience
and I think that's really key if you you
know if you're processing psychic
material because the world is incredibly
stimulating on psychedelics as you know
and can distract you from internal
material so I would say that's to me the
key difference in my missing yeah what
was the original question the difference
between you know taking in
therapeutically versus recreational yeah
definitely the going inward is a huge
factor and it's also just the intention
behind it yes that's right
I think that's a good point that your
one of the things the therapists or
guides do is ask you to set an intention
I want to deal with my mortality I want
to confront my eating disorder you know
whatever it is and it doesn't always
take you there but it often does yeah
and and that becomes kind of the subtext
of the experience and doing it in that
intentional way is so if something
difficult arises if you're there with
the provider you know you can much more
easily go through that experience as we
were talking about before what
as if you're a paranoid at Burning Man
you don't really have any money outs
because you can't who do you trust at
that point so so definitely recommend
taking psychedelics with somebody you
trust the trust aspect is really really
important yeah how much more time do we
have fun okay all right thank you very
much so in the book you kind of paint
this two schools of thought the Timothy
Leary and the Al Hubbard and Leary is to
everyone in the water which seems to
keep coming up here and Hubbard's like
to the elites and the higher-ups and try
to go top-down yeah what do you think is
the optimal way to bring like a new
class of drugs or something to a society
or to help it be integrated where that
doesn't get banned and that it is
properly yeah
shaman there's properly like brought in
yeah
well for people who didn't read the book
I mean there is a I mean you be spotted
I mean a very deliberate contrast
between two key figures one of whom
everybody knows and the other whom
hardly anyone knows al Hubbard was a
very strange man of mystery who was
known as the Johnny Appleseed of LSD or
captain trips in the in the 50s and he
unlike Timothy Leary who he detested
believed that the way to change
consciousness going back to this earlier
question is you turn on the best and the
brightest you turn on the elites in
industry and the church and technology
and he said about doing that he
allegedly turned on about 6,000 people
over the course of his 15-year career
and he went to Silicon Valley and he
started the tradition of engineers in
Silicon Valley using LSD and psilocybin
and he high officials in the church
Catholic Church he turned on and and his
idea was the new consciousness would
filter down Leary was a Democrat a
populist and he thought give it to
everybody right away as soon as possible
he was in a great hurry to do that and
so that was the Mandarin mu in the
populace for you I can't tell you what's
right
you know the the populist view did
contribute to the backlash but is that
Leary's fault you know I don't know I
mean Leary also created the conditions
for this Renaissance by turning on so
many people who ended up becoming the
you know regulators at the FDA you know
they're they're people all through
society now that have been turned on
because of Timothy Leary and that's one
of the reasons people are not reacting
quite as violently to what's going on
they know the territory they're not
terrified by these drugs so it's an
interesting thought experiment but I
don't think it there's an there's an
easy answer they're good arguments on
both sides and if I could maybe rephrase
your question are you asking how can we
responsibly get psychedelics to more
people yeah oh yeah I guess my go-to
answer is education right and let's be
we can get psychedelics to more people
we don't have to just dose the elites
yeah we can provide I think there is a
way that we can get access to more
people
and the kind of let's just do it in a
responsible way that's actually do real
education and I would say in our medical
system as it is today we actually don't
do a very good job by giving people
informed consent about what they're
taking you go to the doctor they write
you a script and you might have like a
long legal list of potential side
effects but you actually have a real
conversation with a doctor about the
risks of the substance you're taking so
I think in many ways our overall system
needs to have be more responsible and we
need to have more open honest
conversations about what we're putting
in our bodies yeah
next question how's it going
just about a month and a half ago I know
I always get curandera who she got
murdered by a westerner from Canada she
went down and she was like one of the
only she was a very famous quote on
there Iowa's Cara and the guy went down
there
and he ended up murdering her because
she she wouldn't give him continual
doses of ayahuasca I wasn't sure if you
guys were aware of that in the community
and I see that as a potential problem
you know that I was a woman who had a
lot of acardo's and a lot of information
as far as ayahuasca and coming from a
female perspective which is actually
rare down there what are your thoughts
on that and are you even aware of what
had happened yes I wasn't I hadn't heard
the story it's a horrible story you know
they've been there been a lot of stories
like that
I mean people victims of sexual abuse
going to Peru curandera is that unlike
this person were not legit and people
need to be careful people need to be
really careful there's a lot at stake
and you know one of the problems with
prohibition always is that you can't
regulate you can't have standards for
the quality of the drug for the training
of the person administering and all
these kind of things when you have
prohibition
ironically anything goes and and that's
why figuring out a sensible way to
incorporate these medicines if indeed
they're proven to be safe and effective
through this trial gives us may give us
a much healthier environment than the
one that exists now yeah I have a degree
at that and I don't have an answer for
that particular I was aware of the
tragedy that happened there but I don't
have an answer for it but I would agree
with you echo what you said that if we
can get out of this drug war and
decriminalize we can actually that gives
us the ability to create the safer
access points and containers yeah I
think are we about we have two questions
okay hi okay I'll keep it short really
excited to be here really nervous to be
asking this question in front of big
urban people my palms are sweaty okay um
I wanted to throw it back to
when you're asked a tough question
earlier about the criticisms of having a
very white male centric book in a very
white male community of the cycle dad
psychedelic community in the United
States you mentioned that you didn't
feel that you were a leader and but I
would say that you've got you know big
group of people that are here and that
you're a newcomer but you've got a lot
of people that are here listening to you
excited to hear you speak and I would
love to hear your thoughts and what the
community can do especially in the
United States to make sure that we're
bringing more diverse voices to the
table and giving space to to more
diverse people to hear you know their
experience with the with the psychedelic
community and working well if that makes
sense yeah no I think that's I think
it's really important work and it's the
same work we need to do in every aspect
of our society it isn't just a problem
in the psychedelic community obviously
we have a sexist society and people need
to take affirmative steps to bring bring
other people unlike themselves into the
community I mean you know this is a book
about science and and by the way science
in general is very sexist we know we
know all the forces that discourage
women to go in and girls from going into
science so that you can't just fix one
little piece you can't just you could
fix the psychedelic community but you
will not have fixed the society so you
have to you have to struggle against
sexism and racism across the board and
the effects will be felt in the
psychedelic society I do think there's
stories that need to be told about
important women in the book you know in
the in this world I always felt bad that
meri kasam onna wasn't a bigger didn't
have a bigger role in the book because I
had interviewed her and I was so
impressed with her work this is the
guide at johns hopkins and and she's
quoted in the book she's there but not
you know she I think she's a I think she
is a hero and in this research program
that does
more attention than I give her and and
and I regret that and I hope I hope the
next time someone writes a book about
that and they're trying to make the book
fresh and not like mine one of the
things they'll do is profile meri kasam
on oh so you know it's not over I mean
it's it's a it's an ongoing process in
terms of bringing african-americans into
the community I think that's a problem
of racism actually I mean think about it
this is an experience where two first
takes a very long time you need leisure
time to have a psychedelic experience
you need to have whole days you can give
to them it also is an experience that
you shy away from if you don't have a
safe environment and what
african-american feels safe in their
environment how many you know our
society has not created the space where
an african-american can can feel safe
having a psychedelic experience so
that's a bigger problem than psychedelic
yeah and I'm gonna add a few things to
that you're right it is something that's
not just in the psychedelic community
this is a broader issue and it's
reflected of course in the psychedelic
community that said if there is any
community that's going to be able to
solve this issue in a way that can
create a model for other parts of
society to mimic it should be the one
that's really self reflective and doing
these psychedelic experiences so I think
we actually have an opportunity in the
psychedelic community to do things that
ripple out and I would actually ask for
everyone here who's involved in these
communities to be proactive I'll speak
for myself I this platform here it's
like it elects seminars I'm gonna use it
to showcase more but I know today it's
two white men on the stage but well I
can hold me to it
this will have more diverse voices I've
been in talks already of several people
about this exact thing and where we'll
go next with us as I think these are
very important topics to discuss another
thing I would add well so there's
openings right you've created an opening
with this book that more people can step
into so the question for me is how do we
help people elevate people to step into
this opening now there's more space than
culture
and culture in general for us to talk
about psychedelics thanks to this book
let's fill that space yeah and oh and
one more thing on this topic which is to
say a large part of the secular
community is taking you know for a good
reason is saying hey gay we're
scientists we're not advocates for
certain policy measures I would say that
if we are looking at changing
psychedelic standing of the psychedelics
we are changing drug policy right and I
would say that if we're going to talk
about changing drug policy we need to
have the people most affected by the bad
drug policy the drug war having a seat
at the table for what the new drug laws
look like and I just want to put that
thought bubble out there better be good
I was gonna say a lot of pressure so
you've kind of made a name both in food
and psychedelics of calling out cultural
elephants in the room so to speak do you
have plans for continuing down the
journey or on now psychedelics or is
there another topic that you think kind
of is spiking a curiosity to continue
and travel down yeah well that's a good
question and I don't have an answer I
you know I don't know what my next
project is I'm this path has been really
interesting to me I don't feel I've
learned everything there is to to be
known about it and that what I'm
learning especially about the mind and
neuroscience has fascinated me and and
I'm also very interested in non
pharmacological altered states of
consciousness and meditation you know my
experience with psychedelics really
opened up meditation for me as it has
for many people it's kind of like you
know psychedelics you could argue are
the entry drugs for meditation and which
I know is not the drug war formulation
but sometimes it works that way so I
don't know where I'm going but I'm very
interested in continuing this
exploration of the mind and finding
other ways to do it and but for the time
being this is my life I mean talking
about this and continuing to change
minds
and be out there as someone who is not a
leader but but an hopefully an explainer
a storyteller someone who can you know
make good use of this opening invite
other people into it and you know I
think we're at a very interesting moment
I mean I think the response to this book
which is absolutely flabbergasted me I
had no reason to believe nor did my
publisher that that Americans were ready
to buy a book about psychedelics you
know we know how to buy a book about
food you know we've all done that but
this was this was a you know so it's
been a real surprise and and now that
I'm over the surprise let's look at the
opportunity well the opportunity is to
have a new kind of conversation about
psychedelics and mental health and that
and we haven't really talked that much
about it but one of the reasons that
people are receptive to this
conversation is not just a fading of 60
stigmas but the fact that mental health
treatment is broken and that we have so
many people suffering in this country
and so few tools to help them only about
half the people with serious mental
illnesses receive any attention from the
system get any care depression rates are
rising suicide rates are rising
addiction rates are rising there's a
real crisis and the tools really there's
been no innovation since the early 90s
we have SSRIs you know and and some very
toxic psychiatric drugs so that's the
really exciting opportunity to treat all
that suffering and and and that's why I
think the future is really bright
because because we need it yeah
thank you thank you so I'm gonna be
around a little longer I'm gonna be out
signing books out there anybody who
wants to get a book signed and but I
want to thank Mike for his role not only
in organizing this event but in
conducting this conversation and that he
is one of the impresarios of that
conversation and so very grateful to him
and Alan and Adam yeah thank you so much
Michael